[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg
guten abend und willkommen zum
nachrichtenüberblick an diesem dienstag
die vom sport hat norbert lehmann
und das sind einige der themen von heute
die aussenministerin in der ukraine
annalena baerbock trifft präsident
selensky und macht sich in butter ein
bild von russischen gräueltaten
politische gewalt auf neuem höchststand
dafür verantwortlich sind laut
innenministerin feser auch querdenker
und radikale kritiker der korona politik
und unverzichtbar ohne menschen mit
migrationshintergrund und ohne
zuwanderung würde das gesundheitssystem
kollabieren sagen experten
nach fast elf wochen krieg und einigen
diskussionen um die besucher deutscher
politiker in der ukraine war heute die
aussenministerin vor ort als erstes
mitglied der regierung stolz und
sichtlich erschüttert ihr versprechen
die internationale gemeinschaft werde
die täter zur verantwortung ziehen aus
kiew dara hassanzadeh
mit dem gedenken der opfer beginnt
annalena baerbock ihren heutigen besuch
in butter dort geschah furchtbare
kriegsverbrechen über 400 menschen
sollen russische soldaten getötet haben
darunter auch kinder
und diese opfer auch das spürt man hier
so eindringlich dieser opfer könnten wir
sein roger ist ein vorort von kia fußes
wie potsdam vor berlin man sieht
spielplätze man sieht supermärkte man
sieht menschen die zur arbeit gehen und
dann sieht man die schlimmsten spuren
von verbrechen genau daneben
ihre nächste station ist ihr team die
zerschossene vorstadt kiew die
ukrainische öffentlichkeit hat sehr wohl
registriert dass die grüne
außenministerin schon zu beginn des
krieges eine harte linie gegen russland
vertreten hat ihre reise soll die wogen
zwischen kiew und berlin klecken
die ukraine ein fester teil europas ich
wünschte mir dass wir auf euren
beitrittswunsch eine starke überzeugende
antwort finden auch wenn es auf dem weg
zur eu vollmitgliedschaft keine
abkürzung geben kann weil was nicht noch
einmal passieren kann sind falsche
versprechungen im laufe des tages gab es
noch ein gespräch mit präsident selensky
es sei offen und freundlich gewesen und
sozusagen als gastgeschenk hatte
außenministerin baerbock auch die
wiedereröffnung der deutschen botschaft
angekündigt
fragen wir katrin eigendorf in kiew wir
haben sie die aussenministerin erlebt
und wie wird ihr besuch in der ukraine
wahrgenommen
annalena baerbock hat hier bei ihrem
besuch einen neuen ton gesetzt in den
beziehungen zwischen beiden ländern die
ja durchaus überschattet waren von
einigen problemen
das ist hier sehr gut angekommen also
präsident selensky hat sie sehr
freundlich empfangen auch die gespräche
mit ihrem amtskollegen cholera sind
eigentlich ein guter austausch so wird
das von ukrainischer seite gesehen auf
augenhöhe gewesen was man der band
ministerin besonders positiv da mal an
was man besonders positiv bewertet ist
dass sie sich hier auch die zeit
genommen hat der opfer sich der opfer
anzunehmen also dass sie in butter sich
wirklich die minute genommen hat auch in
der kirche eine kerze anzuzünden für die
opfer dass sie sich genau angeguckt hat
was da passiert ist dass sie mit
empathie sich auch die geschichten
angehört hat auch mit
frauenorganisationen hier
zusammengetroffen ist die ihr davon
berichtet haben wie viele
vergewaltigungs fälle ist hier auch
gegeben hat das ist auch ein großes
thema hier in der ukraine
also insgesamt wird dieser besuch hier
von ukrainischer seite sehr positiv
bewertet weil baerbock wirklich den
eindruck gemacht hat einerseits
unterstützt deutschland die ukraine
politisch aber will auch konkret etwas
tun
dankeschön für diese einschätzung live
aus kiew katrin eigendorf war das was
dieser krieg den menschen abverlangt
zeigt ein bericht aus dem umkämpften
osten des landes aus recke von dem nahe
gelegenen dorf zirkon ii das liegt nur
20 kilometer von der russischen grenze
entfernt am wochenende konnte es die
ukrainische armee zurückerobern nach
mehr als 70 tagen unter russischer
besatzung der freie journalist am
chiemsee war dort
wir sind unterwegs von hf richtung
russische grenze ganz nah an der front
doch dann geht es plötzlich nicht mehr
weiter
die russen feuern in unsere richtung wir
nehmen einen umweg und erreichen unser
ziel
ich bin ein zirkonia einem dorf ganz nah
fünf kilometer von hier entfernt von
hier hat die russische armee über wochen
die stadt beschossen mit artillerie
wieker zeigt uns wo sie schutz gesucht
haben 74 tage lang lebte die neunjährige
mit ihrer familie in diesem keller
da hat einer geschlafen und da haben
fünf leute geschlafen und hier noch ein
anderer
was mir fehlt frieden und meine freunde
ich vermisse jetzt sogar die schule
wika und die anderen kinder können jetzt
wieder draußen spielen
dieses ehepaar hatte seine einfahrt für
die russischen soldaten beschriftet hier
leben menschen
nacht sind die soldaten betrunken durch
dorf gezogen haben auf fenster
geschossen und sein haus angezündet wir
sind zum nachbarn gegangen um zu gucken
ob er noch lebt wir haben ihn gefunden
er wurde erschossen
im dorf sind die wasserleitungen
zerstört strom erzeugt ein generator und
gas gibt es nicht alexandra vieler
toller ist trotzdem glücklich
endlich freiheit ich bin so glücklich
und
ich habe mein enkelkind
wir verlassen zur coni vorbei an den
trümmern russischer panzer die
ukrainische armee hatte das gebiet
zurückerobert doch immer noch gibt es
russische angriffe
wenn sie fragen an arndt ginzel haben um
19 uhr 30 berichtet er bei zdf heute
live von seinen ukraine erfahrungen in
der zdf- heute- app und auf unseren
social media kanälen außerdem zeigt
frontal um 21 uhr eine ausführliche
reportage von ihm im moment schaut die
welt vor allem auf die ukraine doch auch
in syrien herrscht weiter krieg
bürgerkrieg seit inzwischen elf jahren
die botschaft bei der internationalen
geberkonferenz heute in brüssel syrien
darf nicht vergessen werden eine
milliarde euro hilfe hat deutschland
zugesagt auf die sind mehr als zwölf
millionen hörerinnen und hörer dringend
angewiesen über die katastrophale lage
der menschen an der st resch türkischen
grenze berichtet goliath ein
hilfspaket ist in den letzten wochen
kleiner geworden die zwölfjährige amina
alias zählt ihre vorräte linsen reis
kichererbsen und bulgur daraus muss die
schülerin das fast immer gleich mal
kochen
im laden würde ich gerne kekse kaufen
oder chips aber ich kann nicht wenn ich
kein geld dafür habe auch
das brot in der hilfslieferung ist
weniger geworden
alleine versorgt amina ihre großeltern
beide können sich kaum rühren nach einem
raketenangriff ist sie durch einen
schlaganfall gelähmt und leitet er an
einer nervenkrankheit
wir leben kaum wir sind mehr tut einen
tag essen wir zehnter essen wir nicht
der krieg in der ukraine hat die not der
syrer verschärft die preise explodieren
krankenhäuser in nordsyrien müssten
schließen immer mehr kinder müssen
arbeiten während die spender müde sind
vom sich hinziehenden konflikt sagen
hilfsorganisationen
wir reden heute von 12 millionen
schülern die nicht genug zu essen haben
und es war noch nie so schwer für uns
wir begannen das jahr mit nur 24 prozent
der gelder die wir brauchen also müssen
wir den hungrigen die essens hilfe
wegnehmen und sie den hungernden geben
hin dass darwin
vor dem krieg versorgte syrien sich
selbst heute ist die spärliche eigene
weizenernte bedroht die bauern leiden
unter dem klimawandel und können sich
kaum noch dünger und pestizide leisten
deren preise sich durch den ukraine
krieg mehr als verdoppelt haben
ein neuer bericht der uno zeigt wie sehr
die zeit drängt um die erderwärmung zu
begrenzen
demnach könnte schon in vier jahren die
jahresdurchschnittstemperatur erstmals
mehr als 1,5 grad über dem
vorindustriellen niveau liegen die
wahrscheinlichkeit dafür liegt bei fast
50 prozent
vor sieben jahren war sie noch 0 0
würde die 1,5 grad marke tatsächlich
überschritten hieße das laut den
forschern nicht automatisch dass das
unumkehrbar wäre wir müssen unsere
bemühungen zum klimaschutz aber
dramatisch verstärken was bedeutet die
schnellere ehrt erhitzung für mensch
tier und die erde in der zdf- heute- app
beantworten unsere experten die
wichtigsten fragen rund um die
auswirkungen der klimakrise
immer mehr menschen in deutschland
glauben sie müssten ihre politische
meinung auch mit radikalen mitteln
durchsetzen das zeigt die aktuelle
kriminalitätsstatistik
demnach stieg im vergangenen jahr die
zahl der straftaten mit politischem
hintergrund auf
55.000 48 fast überall zeichnet sich
eine deutliche zunahme ab sowohl bei den
kleineren delikten wie
sachbeschädigungen oder beleidigung aber
auch bei den gewalttaten auch der
protest gegen die korona politik spielt
eine rolle klaus brodbeck
dezember vergangenen jahres ein
fackelzug von corona leugnen vor dem
wohnhaus der sächsischen
gesundheitsministerin das milieu
radikalisiert sich und kann nicht mehr
klassischen politischen kategorien also
rechts oder links zugeordnet werden ein
ganz wesentlicher teil der taten ist im
zusammenhang mit den protesten gegen die
korona maßnahmen begangen worden dabei
handelt es sich vielfach um verstöße
gegen das versammlungsrecht
beleidigungen und bedrohungen auch aber
gewaltdelikte wie körperverletzungen das
hinzu der exzessiven gewalttaten
ausgerechnet diese eher diffuse
kategorie wächst am schnellsten das
bundeskriminalamt spricht von einer
heterogenen mit szene höchst
unterschiedlicher personen und gruppen
was sie eint ist neben der thematik in
weiten teilen auch eine
insgesamt staatskritischen bis
staatsfeindliche haltung
größte bedrohung allerdings bleibt wie
schon seit jahren der rechtsextremismus
von dem mehr als 40 prozent aller
politischen gewalttaten ausgingen in
einer nachfolgenden pressekonferenz
kritisiert der verband der
beratungsstellen für betroffene solcher
gewalt zählweise und zuordnung der fälle
durch die behörden leider müssen wir wie
bereits in den vorjahren auch von einer
hohen anzahl nicht registrierter rechter
rassistischer und antisemitischer
gewalttaten sowie von einer eklatanten
unter fassung bei polizei und justiz
ausgehen wodurch eine massive gefahr
besteht dass tatsächlich das lagebild
verbessert wird nie zuvor seit ihrer
fasson gab es mehr politisch motivierte
kriminalität krone hat das noch
beschleunigt
ohne zugewanderte würde in deutschland
einiges kaum noch funktionieren
besonders in krankenhäusern arztpraxen
oder in der pflege ein viertel der
beschäftigten dort hat ausländische
wurzeln
ohne sie würde das gesundheitssystem
kollabieren sagt der zuständige
sachverständigenrat umso wichtiger wäre
dass ausländische abschlüsse schneller
anerkannt werden katrin lindner wie geht
es ihnen heute frau fink vor fünfeinhalb
jahren kam wahrheit marie okabe von
syrien nach brandenburg er arbeitet in
einer klinik südlich von berlin und ist
froh darüber doch mit der langen
wartezeit für die zulassungsprüfung für
das deutsche gesundheitswesen hat er
nicht gerechnet wie sich die approbation
prüfung bestanden habe den termin dafür
bekommen habe und bestanden habe ich ein
jahr und zehn monate verloren laut
jahresbericht des sachverständigenrates
für integration und migration hatten im
jahr 2013 rund 17 prozent der
erwerbstätigen in den gesundheits und
pflegeberufen ein migrationshintergrund
sechs jahre später 22.5 ohne sie stünde
das gesundheitssystem vor dem kollaps so
die wissenschaftler sie fordern mehr
effizienz und transparenz bei den
zulassungen
wir als sachverständigen rat empfehlen
also dass es eine anlaufstelle innerhalb
der bundesländer geben soll und für
anwerbung aus dem ausland eine zentrale
anlaufstelle im bund im krankenhaus
ludwigsfelde teltow reicht es ihnen
nicht lücken mit personal aus anderen
ländern zu stopfen man muss vielleicht
auch die zugangsvoraussetzung ein
bisschen auch deren realitäten anpassen
die deutsche hochschule ausbildung ist
noch sehr traditionell seither gebracht
insofern wird wird wahrscheinlich auch
veränderungen geben müssen den ersten
job zu bekommen ist für erste wie
wahrheit marie okabe die größte hürde er
hat 75 bewerbungen geschrieben es gab
nur eine antwort aus diese klinik
wir gehen ins ausland auf die
philippinen dort hat gerade der
diktatorensohn ferdinand marcos junior
haushoch die präsidentschaftswahlen
gewonnen der 64 jährige tritt damit das
amt an das einst sein berüchtigter vater
ferdinand marcos senior innehat dessen
ära steht für menschenrechtsverletzungen
folter und tausende tote mit seinem sohn
an der spitze fürchten kritiker nun
einen rückfall in düstere zeiten und
freuler berichtet
ferdinand marcos junior hat es geschafft
nach einem wahlkampf voller emotionen
hat er den familien clan der markus
wieder an die macht gebracht vor 36
jahren wurde sein vater der diktator von
der bevölkerung vertrieben wegen
korruption und massenhaften
menschenrechtsverletzungen nun wird sein
sohn gefeiert
ich erwarte dass eure unterstützung und
euer vertrauen in mich nicht schwinden
denn wir haben uns so viel vorgenommen
für die zukunft
der sohn hat einen wahlkampf im internet
geführt dort hat er die brutale
regierungszeit seines vaters umgedeutet
als glanzvolle epoche die jungen
anhänger markus kenne nur seine version
der geschichte denn mehr als zehn
stunden täglich sind viele in den
sozialen medien unterwegs
die philippinen zu vereinen diese
botschaft hat gesiegt erklärt uns die
begeisterte mit lager wir alle sind so
glücklich
markus gegner protestieren auf den
straßen von manila sprechen von
wahlbetrug
schamlose lügen und wahlfälschungen
finden im ganzen land statt
die mehrheit der philippinen fürchtet
nicht den rückfall in eine marcos
diktatur
sie sind fasziniert von der idee des
starken mannes
zum ersten mal seit 59 jahren hat die
queen nicht an der feierlichen eröffnung
des britischen parlaments teilgenommen
die 96 jährige sei nicht mobil genug
hieß es aus dem buckingham palast
deshalb präsentierte an ihrer stelle ihr
sohn die sogenannte queen's speech prinz
charles verlas das programm der
regierung für die kommenden
sitzungsperiode geplant sind unter
anderem gesetze um die folgen steigender
lebenshaltungskosten abzufedern
britische medien bezeichneten charts
auftritt als historischen moment die
queen hat in letzter zeit schon öfter
repräsentative aufgaben abgegeben
tja jetzt zur fußball-bundesliga norbert
da tut sich was bei borussia dortmund
erneut verliert der bvb einen
schlüsselspieler ja und die bundesliga
eine echte attraktion stürmers darling
holland der wechsel zu manchester city
für die ablösesumme von 75 millionen
euro
es ist vollbracht nur einige
vertragsmodalitäten müssen noch geklärt
werden bereits gestern ist er in holland
wohl schon in belgien gesichtet worden
in diesem krankenhaus zum medizincheck
um sich die reise nach manchester zu
sparen pep guardiola sind sparen dagegen
nicht für den topstürmer dürften
insgesamt mit ablöse handgeld und
weiteren nebengeräuschen gut 200
millionen euro zu zahlen sein oder sogar
mehr
ich weiß dass da draußen viel über geld
gesprochen wird dabei dieser transfer
wird neue maßstäbe setzen
dafür gibt es aber einen stürmer mit
sensationeller treffer quote für
dortmund erzielte er in 88 spielen 85
tore
und es gibt auch ein bvb neuzugang
nationalspieler karim adeyemi von rb
salzburg r wechselt für angeblich 30
millionen euro und erhält einen vertrag
bis 2027
zum uefa kongress in wien da geht es um
die umstrittene reform der fußball-
champions- league ab der saison 2004 und
20 25 daran sollen statt 36 vereine
statt ich würde mir daran sollten dann
sollen dann 36 statt bisher 32 vereine
teilnehmen in einem neuen liga system in
gut zwei jahren muss für den
champions-league-sieg mehr gespielt
werden bei ihrem wiener treffen hat die
uefa die königsklasse aufgestockt vier
teams mehr als bislang eine gruppenphase
gibt es nicht mehr 36 vereine bilden
eine liga vier heim- und vier
auswärtsspiele wird es geben gegen acht
verschiedene gegner acht spiele
mindestens bis zur ko-runde und nicht
zehn die zuvor einmal geplant bislang
sind es sechs
wir erwarten dass jetzt alle spiele
wirklich zählen die klubs werden viele
verschiedene gegner bekommen und nicht
nur drei wie ihnen gruppen bisher
um mehr als 60 spiele auf 189 wird die
champions league wachsen ein
mehrstelliger millionen gewinn auch in
europa und conference league werden 36
teams spielen
und die uefa hat auch beschlossen
eröffnungsspiel der fußball heimat 2024
münchen und das finale natürlich in
berlin das wird viele freund zum schluss
noch marilyn monroe die nach wie vor
ihre fans hat andy warhol hat sie auf
seine leinwand gebannt
ein bild das jeder kennt und das viele
gerne hätten einer hat es jetzt
ersteigert in vier minuten für
195 millionen dollar ein bild mit einer
story erschossene marylin heißt es weil
eine aktionskünstlerin in warhols
atelier mit der pistole drauf feuerte
heiß wird es morgen örtlich bis zu 30
grad über den norden zieht etwas regen
die details hat gleich katja und
marietta slomka begrüßt sie um viertel
vor zehn im heute journal
danke für ihr interesse einen schönen
abend noch und bis morgen wenn sie mögen
auch wieder sehen
[Musik]
guten abend morgen wird für die meisten
von uns der heißeste tag der woche das
sehen sie hier ganz gut an dieser geld
man der orangen farbe aber der
nordwesten bleibt von dieser hitze
verschob das liegt an regenwolken die
über den norden hinweg ziehen mit diesen
kleinen tief wie heute nacht schon im
nordosten morgen sich da in ein tief
über großbritannien heran und das sieht
dann weiter richtung nordseeküste heute
nacht also regen dass etwas in
mecklenburg vorpommern oder auch im
südlichen niedersachsen im norden
stärker bewölkt als im süden das wird
für viele eine sehr lange mainacht mit
tiefsttemperaturen zwischen 17 grad in
westsachsen und 8 grad in nordfriesland
die höchsttemperaturen morgen liegen an
den küsten von nord- und ostsee bei 15
bis 18 grad die allermeisten von uns
dürfen sich auf frühsommerliche
22 bis 30 grad einstellen über
norddeutschland sehen die etwas
dichteren wolken die auch etwas regen
dabei haben zu wenig regen um der dürre
einhalt zu gebieten im nordosten bei
südwestwind im süden ist es dagegen sehr
sonnig am donnerstag gibt es noch einige
regenschauer und auch gewitter besonders
im osten und am alpenrand und dann nimmt
die gewitterneigung von tag zu tag ab
guten abend